i got my holy cat shirt on that's what i
call it look at these amazing holes my
cats put in here they keep tearing at it
it's their favorite one and it's also my
most comfortable one watching gravity
falls we gotta just be comfortable
episode two today that last episode was
a lot of fun i hear it just gets better
from here on out so subscribe and click
that notification bell get notified when
our next reaction for gravity falls is
up make sure to hit that like button
full length watch along so we stick up
with the time code or over at our
patreon page over there we cover many
shows with the same tier you get the
option for reaction highlights and watch
alongs included thanks to the boys over
at prepper for edit
that's how you say it let's do it
[Music]
are you ready for the ultimate challenge
i'm always ready then you know what this
means
surprise
sure
go mountain
go go go go go go go yes
family fun day genius we're cutting off
work and having one of those you know
bonding type deals grunkle stan is this
gonna be anything like our last family
bonding day
you call that ben franklin
the county jail was so cold all right
maybe i haven't been the best summer
caretaker but i swear today we're gonna
have some real family fun now who wants
to put on some blindfolds and get into
my car
[Laughter]
oh jesus
[Music]
there's something about creepy old men
in animated properties that cracks me up
they're classic archetype
not as much fun and real in real life no
i'll show you how a real man fishes
oh god
i've never had fishing buddies before
the guys from the lodge won't go with me
they don't like or trust me
i think he actually wants to fish with
us i think you're bait that that's hand
stitching you know
it's the gobbledy walker what done did
it it had a long neck like a g-raf and
wrinkly skin like like this gentleman
right here huh
oh
no
you gotta believe me
attention all units we got ourselves a
crazy old man
[Laughter]
no respect for your elders
now let's untie this boat and get out on
that lake
if we can snag a photo of it we could
split the prize 50 50.
that's 250.
[Laughter]
[Music]
your kids could go waste your time on
some epic monster finding adventure or
you could spend the day learning how to
tie knots and skewer worms with your
great uncle stan
oh he really wants the fish yeah he
wants to bond for real
[Laughter]
so what do you say
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's real
i bought 17 disposable cameras two on my
ankle three in my jacket four for each
of you three extras in this bag and one
under my hat what if you fall in the
water yeah
okay everybody let's test our cameras
out
[Laughter]
as i repeat don't lose your cameras
lose the cameras don't dude i just threw
two away
we have 12 cameras so what's the plan
throw more camera
there's a burning question which my
heart longs to ask of you oh reginald
hey want to hear a joke
here goes
my ex-wife still misses me
but her aim is getting better
it's funny because marriage is terrible
oh goodness no
i like that joke
go
[Laughter]
[Music]
but but what was that noise then i heard
a monster noise
oh
no
we ditched him over nothing
hey guys do you feel that
whoa whoo
this is it
come on this is our chance
what's wrong with you guys
yes dude it's not that hard all right
all you got to do take the photo
man do it do it do it
take the photo
take the shot
i'm so
bad photo
he's got 12 more cameras though he can
do it for 10.
[Music]
yes there you go
[Music]
[Music]
don't worry dude
oh geez that's so
[Laughter]
god molly frustrating can you please
tell me more funny stories pop pop
anything for my fish
fever
[Music]
we're still beavers
angry beavers
[Music]
oh oh my god people are being murdered
fish are gonna eat good tonight
[Music]
easy easy
[Laughter]
[Music]
i think there might be a cave behind
i love that there joke that's so funny
oh
bet you wish you had your camera now
yeah wait it's stuck
oh thank goodness
torture the beasts
dissect it and see what makes it tick
please don't lose that camera
it's a robot what the
[Music]
you can still get money hey guys come
check this out
[Music]
that's an amazing invention
ah
twist
i just wanted attention
oh like your
uncle putin added up a biomechanical
brainwave generator and then i learned
to operate a stick shift with my beard
okay yeah
well when you get to be an old fella
like me nobody pays any attention to you
anymore my own son hasn't visited me in
months stoic monthly
[Music]
dude i guess the real like monster is
you two
sorry i just like boom just popped into
my head there did you ever talk to your
son about how you felt no sir i got to
work straight on the robot
so much for the photo contest we still
have one roll of film left what do you
want to do with it
make memories it's still a pretty
[ __ ] amazing invention yeah
i'm sure that magazine would give you
money the only dinosaur we want to hang
out with is right here save your
sympathy i've been having a great time
without you making friends talking to my
reflection
i guess i gotta wear this ankle bracelet
oh jesus
oh god everybody get together say
fishing fishing dude am i in the frame
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh
[Music]
the real monster
of course
why did the pelican get kicked out of
the restaurant i don't care because he
had a very big bill
that was a good pelican joke
water
rock and roll rock and roll belly
he's like what the hell do you think
you're doing
i came in here to harass you to feed me
instead you'd make me a joke
hell yeah that was my jam that one
absolutely that was my jam that was
hilarious i liking the style a little
bit towards how i sort of feel with
family guy versus american dad
where family guys a lot of like cutaway
bits and
uh you don't really care about the story
you know but it's funny
and i like i love family guy but
american dad has they don't do a bunch
of cutaways and stuff like they have
bits whatever it's wacky it's hygienics
is larger than life it's you know
whatever
however it's very um
it's still like there's a storyline
every episode and i actually kind of
care about the story yeah
and that's how i felt here like when it
came to the cameras you could really
feel that because i think if they really
put you in that position of if we had an
opportunity to find some type of
legendary creature in the woods or the
lake
we'd want a camera for such a situation
like that you'd want 16. so you feel
that whenever they're just throwing the
cameras but it's really hilarious just
like
the unnecessary reasons to keep throwing
the cameras in there and it just
escalated so well to the point where uh
what's what's the big guy's name seuss i
think
yeah he starts throwing it at them at
the creature oh my god i love a good
absurd running gag like this yes yeah
yeah that was freaking hysterical
and then uh and yeah like the whole
story line with the uncle like being
feeling lonely i was trying to wonder i
was wondering how it would eventually
tie back around
and i thought they actually did a really
good job on doing that it was really
well constructed you introduce the
father who's lonely at the top of it do
the plot just reveal make it the wrap
around with you know it's important to
spend time with your loved ones and
sometimes the people the older
generation aren't the best and just
putting their heart out there or having
a discussion you know like the men
setting their ways that they they don't
they don't talk with their hearts they
talk with their actions and you gotta
like recognize that i thought that was
hysterical and the bits were just
bits through the roof here this is a
hilarious ass episode oh absolutely one
and it made for actually like a a
satisfying twist because that old man
like crazy old man archetype is like so
well worn that yeah it skates right past
and it's goofy and you're like okay
that's a bit character and then when
they did the reveal it cracked me up a
because i legitimately wasn't expecting
it and it's great for a character that
archetype to be like no this is gonna be
i'm gonna bank off of that and use it to
my advantage almost and then yeah just
the comedy of that character almost
deconstructing that and the whole thing
went like did you have a conversation
nope just got straight to work on my big
giant aquatic sea monster and yeah they
made a really good i think back and
forth between the two plots because with
dipper and mabel you are in something
that's more you know it's got an actual
direction it's headed and then when you
cut back to grunkle stan you get like
any and all possible bits for this guy
just hanging out on the lake trying to
connect with people and like what to
where he gets this
bracelet
which
somebody's got an ankle press like
well that's the thing is like it skates
i i appreciate a show like this because
you know i mean we're both big rick and
morty fans and both big like you know we
enjoy some family yeah we like the zany
animated [ __ ] and and those shows get
edgy and this show i feel like has a
nice balance because it's aimed and it
has to be appropriate for middle-aged
you know young teenagers and stuff they
could they can hint at things like that
that if you understand the implication
you're like oh no but they're also not
so edgy that they're you know into tv
mature territory and so yeah i think
that just the voice of the show is
really well pitched that way i mean yeah
even like the little girl mabel when
she's like in the hamster ball and
fighting those the boys being attracted
to her yes actually drawing them in yeah
yeah they're like bones and awesome yeah
i love the glass bit because yes yeah
because it's such a well wardrobe on
like all when you're on them bicycles
and the way they handled that reveal
where it's just a close-up on the guy
and they cut to the shot of the two and
that was like no reason they would
and yeah great because you know where
it's going and yet as a visual gag it
works perfectly and it's such a great
punchline because yeah when movies and
shows do that now mainly movies it's
like oh man this is so i've never seen
that once in my life of people walking
carrying glasses yeah
like that
and so it's it's in movies all the time
so to be able to pull a good that
doesn't mean i feel like adults might
get that joke better even oh yeah it's
not a mature joke but it's like classic
slapstick yeah yeah so uh i thought that
was hilarious and i even thought the
chase was like exciting yeah when
they're running away from the dragon you
want them to take the photos they
actually
put the dragon scales like the scale of
the dragon the way it's uh animated uh
it's kind of scary it's not scary but it
provides a sense of peril yeah you get
swept up in the intensity on on like the
appropriate level for what kind of
cartoon you're watching like it's not
just always zany funny it's like
sometimes it's still zany but it's also
yeah pulling you into like oh god i hope
this thing doesn't like knock their bone
over or something and yeah the camera's
made for a perfect
both
bit of tension building and also just
humor yeah perfect back and forth and i
do like what you said earlier about how
they take like the kooky old
man who's like skeevy conniving and like
instantly i thought right away like oh
no this fishing trip has an ulterior
motive he's got to be like baiting them
into getting the monsters yeah i thought
his whole motive was the monster yeah
and then come to find out that he didn't
care it actually took me by surprise and
to do that on your second episode as
you're still getting accustomed to these
characters i think is very beneficial uh
for your show to do things like that
because usually a show when you have a
character such as that they would wait a
while longer before you do an episode
that really shows they have a heart yeah
or sure like they hit that that in the
first episode would like get anything
you want in the gift shop but in this
one the the whole episode his
his time here was he just wanted family
time yeah and uh and he is lonely so i i
think that that was a really clever move
because it gets me more emotionally
invested in the character now too but
they didn't lose any of the
fun
uh unintentional creepiness that he
gives off to other characters in this
gravity falls world
all right guys thank you guys so much
for being here thank you all recommended
this show thanks for blind wave for
starting to cover this because we didn't
have recommendations if it wasn't for
you guys starting i guess i'll just
mention blind way of every video right
we've got to find a way to shoot again
we have we me if we miss a day where we
don't mention blind wave you got gotta
tell us fellow quirky merc eric quitely
whitley whitley there's no e in there
sorry i just might be right i see
whiteness and i'm just like white i
might be wrong whitely whitley subscribe
click that bell hit that like button
check us out on patreon last but not
least let's do a p
daniel gallacher guess what buddy we're
leaving the pharmacy for this shout out
because the first person who came to my
mind today i was like who should we
shout out i was like daniel gallagher
because every time i see your profile
pic you know you got this youthful
presence about you and i feel like you
would fit in perfectly as an animated
character in a show like this plus being
from scotland you would bring a natural
accent with you that would heighten
things even further give the show a
little more personality plus i gotta
imagine you come from the land of the
loch ness monster so you would be the
perfect person to help trap and track a
creature like that so hey man i hope you
have some interest in this show because
i don't know for some reason now i'm
just going to think of you whenever i
watch it true so hope you're doing well
happy holiday season and merry christmas
to you
[Music]